jean picq benz bonjour merci d'être avec
nous dans la matinale de rtl france le
gouvernement belge a donc la volonté
d'imposer la vaccination aux soignants
comment le secteur de la santé réagit à
ce souhait du gouvernement est ce que
comme c'est le cas en france il y a des
soignants qui s'y opposent
oui comme syndicats on a dit il n'y a
aucune raison de ne pas te laisser la
crimée café c'est notre proposition mais
on veut encore parlé avec le méritera
michel santé 500 des bleus qui a demandé
au gouvernement de faire une obligation
de la vaccination pour les personnes
soignantes mais nous on en demande
encore une réunion avec lui parfois avec
ça veut dire quoi booster gens
qu'ils veulent pas parce que ça aussi en
belgique on n'a pas trop de personnel
entre des soignants de ce fait on va
voir demain une réunion puis là on voit
fois pour augmenter la vaccination est
ta tête tout à bruxelles ici que c'est
en belgique le nord de la flandre et la
wallonie là on était certain à 90% des
partenaires des gens vaccinés mais à
bruxelles on n'est qu'à 60 % et à cause
de ça on veut augmenter et faire oublier
aux obligations de la vaccination en
belgique et justement en ce qui concerne
les sanctions éventuelles de ceux qui ne
voudraient pas vaccinés quelle est votre
position
le dis on a pas de soignants en belgique
non plus
les gens ils ont travaillé très fort
dans la première vague à 2,80 va et
maintenant les licenciés
et indiquant donc davantage de dialogue
plutôt que des sanctions c'est ça
finalement oui oui et le blick a promis
qu'il y aura encore des discussions un
de temps en temps
dans ma vie passion alors ce seront tous
toutes les personnes qui travaillent
dans le médical qui seraient concernés
ou alors ce n'est pas encore défini
tout à fait défini mais nous on vit
quand ce n'était pas dans son mandat
et quoi avec les gens qui travaillent
avec les jeunes ou les handicapés et là
aussi on va avoir une discussion là
dessus et on l'entend l'invitation alors
dans le même temps la belgique a annoncé
vendredi 20 août un assouplissement au
1er septembre le pays dans le top 4 un
des pays européens les plus vaccinée
dans ce contexte est-ce que l'obligation
vaccinale elle reste quand même
nécessaire pour essayer quand même un
grand monsieur parce que on va
assouplir s'est assouplie y tu
ne tombes a applaudi en flandre en
wallonie et à bruxelles et là problème
justement quelle est la situation plus
précisément à bruxelles aujourd'hui
on est vaccinés à
90% à bruxelles on n'est qu'un soit en
est là on doit pour vacciner beaucoup de
gens
tels les plus jeunes en belgique
ça a duré un peu plus longtemps beaucoup
de gens qui ont été à la maison au maroc
en afrique et ils sont en train de
retourner à ce moment orties et bleu
ciel a décidé de faire
tout le monde qui travaille dans le soin
vous parliez des plus jeunes le
gouvernement lui envisage de permettre
l'ouverture des boîtes de nuit ce type
de décision est ce que c'est risqué ou
pas selon vous
les nouveaux
[Musique]
un petit mot
du premier c'est parce qu'on passe à 2
16 et là il ya aussi un problème parce
que la belgique n'est pas si grand et tu
t'es fait
de déplacer des bus est là
et là il ya quand même un problème un
problème à cause de ça la partie
nationale bat vraiment augmenté il ya
des opérations mises en place pour pour
conclure
est ce qu'il ya des opérations qui sont
mises en place pour inciter justement la
population sur l'accident j'ai encore lu
ce matin ils vont patiner dans des
magasins il ya des pouces qui tourne
dans bruxelles où les heures à venir
café notons
une piqûre et y penser des coureurs pour
leurs familles et pour aller travailler
et une population globalement qui n'est
pas réticente
willaya problème
les moyens
merci beaucoup jean pierre laurens
d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce matin
sur rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
secrétaire fédéral du syndicat
socialiste mais péter k